during those times a lot of [ __ ]  people wrote us off the dynasty's over  draymond's wash he can't do this he  can't do that steph curry has no help he  can't carry a team you go down the list  you have to know the disrespect is  unbelievable by the way clay keeps  speaking out on it clay doesn't talk  about any [ __ ] thing clay doesn't  even [ __ ] talk hey man it's a lot of  basketball left to be played like i'm  not  gonna sit here and act like man we're  sitting in first place at game 60 like  it's game 15.  let's not get ahead of ourselves  what i do know is we have a damn good  team and  we will continue to grow we will get  clay back we will get wiseman back and  those are two more important pieces to  what we're trying to rebuild here and i  think if we continue to work we can give  ourselves a real chance and boy  don't let us win a [ __ ] championship  because you gotta [ __ ] hear it from  me  in